Hello there everyone this is going to be my
full obi-wan kenobi episode 1 video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs for star wars for
everything that happened during the prequels
as well as what's happening in the future
with luke skywalker in the original trilogy
there's even a little bit of stuff going on
with grogu now in this part of the timeline
so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get them all hello hello
careful for spoilers from everything from episode
one if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start
at the beginning of the episode and work our
way through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs and wtf moments as we go along but they
actually started episode one with the big recap
of everything that happened to obi-wan kenobi in
his story with darth vader anakin skywalker during
the prequels ending with the very end of revenge
of the sith as they all go their separate ways
the actual opening scene began with a special new
obi-wan kenobi theme song over the title and one
of the big things with the music for the series
is they did get a separate composer who's not john
williams to come back and do music for the entire
episodes but john williams himself came back
specifically just to do one piece of music and it
was actually the theme song for obi-wan himself
because he said technically in the original
trilogy he didn't actually create a separate
special theme song just for alec guinness's
obi-wan kenobi the actual opening scene of
the episode is a shot on course onto the
jedi temple with a bunch of young lings as
order 66 is going down they're on the middle
of training and if it wasn't clear they want
to show you that this young girl in training here
at the temple during order 66 was a young version
of reva who eventually does get twisted to the
dark side and becomes an inquisitor as an adult
the name of the jedi master that's in the
middle of training them is called velti
she winds up dying to protect them as you see
all the other clone troopers going around killing
everyone around the rest of the temple they don't
actually show you the scene of anakin skywalker
killing that group of younglings but somewhere in
the background he is killing a bunch of young kids
just like these ones that are escaping r.i.p
younglings i think this is also meant to set
up the idea of what happened to some of the
inquisitors too because they gave you a little bit
of backstory but they don't really start talking
about that till episode two so i'll talk more
about them when they show up in the episode even
though some of them probably do get away it sounds
like reva winds up being turned to the dark side
because she eventually does become an inquisitor
so that means that some of these other children
might have become inquisitors too as part of these
forces in present day but as they run away you
can hear the emperor's voice repeating on all the
clone troopers comms saying execute order 66 over
and over again then they jump to 10 years later
which is meant to be the present day of the
series where most of the series takes place
on the streets of tatooine i believe this town
is meant to be anchor head we actually went there
a couple times during book of boba fett there
were some deleted scenes there during a new hope
most of the rest of the episode on tatooine takes
place in and around anchor heads so that's why i
think that this is the village at the beginning of
the episode they don't waste any time in showing
you the jedi inquisitors and what their mission is
i tried to find a special name for the inquisitor
ship but all the references to it are just calling
it the inquisitor's transport but it's meant to be
evocative of later ships like kylo ren's black
ship they show you the grand inquisitor reva who
they're calling the third sister and the fifth
brother played by sun king most of you remember
sun kang from all the fast and furious movies
he's not very recognizable in all that makeup
most of these characters like all the inquisitor
characters you probably saw during star wars
rebels at some point like the grand inquisitor
character actually showed up during clone wars
and during rebels there's a lot that happens
with their characters in the next couple of
episodes i'll wait till my episode 2 video to talk
about what happens to him because you know what
happens to some of these characters like some
of them do show up much later in the timeline
so it's a little bit easier to tell who might die
who might not die based on that but the whole idea
with the inquisitors is they basically used to be
jedi or jedi trainees or padawans who were turned
to the dark side and are now going around hunting
people for the emperor and for darth vader their
home base is called the fortress inquisitorius
that showed up during star wars rebels it shows
up during jedi fallen order you go there a
couple times during a couple different series
it was located on a different moon also inside
the mustafar system so like darth vader's castle
on mustafar was pretty close by to where the
inquisitors were but they weren't on the same
planet and there's this whole thing that they set
up with the reva character like she's meant to be
this hardcore ambitious character who wants to win
more favor with the emperor and with darth vader
throughout the episode there are a couple
different times when the other inquisitors
take her to task for being too ambitious they're
kind of trying to set up the idea that evil will
always wind up defeating itself like the same way
that darth vader eventually wound up defeating the
emperor it wasn't luke skywalker evil winds up
killing evil it's meant to dovetail with that
whole conversation that the grand inquisitor
has when he's trying to find that other rogue
jedi character the jedi can't help themselves they
have to help everyone it's all about the jedi code
but like i said it's meant to dovetail with the
idea that reva is also going after the other
inquisitors because she's more ambitious so the
inquisitors are also kind of hunting themselves
so to speak you see a couple their force abilities
they whip out a couple of their lightsabers they
all have hilts that are kind of crazy meant
to be kind of like the grand inquisitor's
lightsaber hilt i think that he's one of the
only ones with a double-bladed lightsaber though
most of that is taken from star wars rebels even
though he doesn't have like the crazy looking sith
eyes from star wars rebels like that might have
something to do with what happens to him later in
the series or later in the timeline they use this
ironic scene where the grand inquisitor winds up
revealing this rogue jedi through him trying to
help the other person by stopping the knife from
hitting his body using the force and as he escapes
the whole talk about him being the smaller fish
in them looking for bigger quarry is all about
obi-wan kenobi obviously he is the bigger fish the
more famous jedi that darth vader has been looking
for for the last 10 years unsuccessfully but the
way they talk about it the other inquisitors like
the regular ones don't really care about finding
him they don't think that it's even possible like
we failed we're not gonna find him he's hidden
somewhere too deeply the hunt for obi-wan is all
about reva trying to win favor with the emperor
then the actual obi-wan kenobi revealed during
the series the scene of him working on the line
of that giant sand creature as they exhume it for
all the different parts is meant to be an ironic
twist on what you just saw the rogue jedi wound
up revealing himself because he was compelled to
help someone else his altruism wound up revealing
him whereas obi-wan kind of does the opposite and
he chooses to hide his abilities by not helping
the person being bullied by the foreman obviously
we know obi-wan is eventually going to use his
abilities he's eventually going to help people he
is a good character but thankfully by the end of
the episode he does agree to go find leia and even
though the next part of this episode is all about
his relationship with luke and with lars owen and
what's going on in this part of the timeline
on tatooine around the owen large farmstead
most of this early part of the series is actually
about young leia's character that's probably one
of the biggest surprises because it's the first
time we've ever actually seen her in live action
this young before but they reveal for the last 10
years he's just been living out of this cave with
this meagre belongings he hasn't built his hut
yet that you see during a new hope that probably
happens later in the timeline maybe we'll see
a teaser for that at the end of the series like
okay i'll finally build myself an actual home now
he's got an r2 unit serving as a watchdog for him
just alerting him to anyone's presence there's a
jawa that it seems like he's been trading with for
the last several years called tikka they make this
big joke about the job was just stealing anything
that's not bolted down and then selling it back to
him as if they found it like oh here's the thing
that you found missing and one of the big easter
eggs here is actually the t16 model that you see
luke skywalker playing with during a new
hope when he's talking to c-3po and r2d2
turns out that was built by obi-wan kenobi
and given to him as a 10th birthday present
even though later in the episode you see owen
lars try to throw it back in his face like hey
don't give him any ideas too late for that seems
like he really wants to be a pod racer someday
they do have this joke about him sitting on top of
their hut playing pod racer like he's making all
these motions wearing goggles just like anakin
skywalker was during phantom menace like father
like son like mother like daughter because during
the episodes they also remark about how leia
is acting just like padme would act they said
at that whole running story line with the other
jedi appearing on tatooine obviously talking
about the rogue jedi that the inquisitors were
chasing down here's some belongings that we stole
from his ship giving obi-wan probably the most
ptsd of all ptsd flashbacks obi-wan kenobi
also literally calls for qui-gon jinn's help
making me think that there's going to be a qui-gon
jinn easter egg or a cameo scene before the end of
the series where he shows up to teach him how to
become a force ghost because they still have to
do that that's a big part of the timeline obi-wan
have you done as i asked have you trained the boy
master qui-gon how are you here all the nightmares
that you see him have the different scenes are
meant to be the most wtf moments from each of the
prequel movies all the way back to phantom menace
like you even see anakin as a child when he leaves
the t16 model behind for luke the other rogue jedi
tries to give him this big call to action and it
takes a couple times in the episode because each
time someone tells him that he needs to help
out he says no i'm not going to do anything
the funny thing too is that when he tells the
other jedi to go out into the sand and bury
his lightsaber so that they won't find it he
literally has done that himself because at the
end of the episode he walks out to the middle of
the desert to dig up his old lightsaber hilt and
anakin skywalker's old lightsaber hilt which
he'll eventually give to luke skywalker
the other huge reveal here to the other rogue
jedi is that he's started going by the name
ben these past several years like he isn't using
the name obi-wan kenobi he's trying to encourage
other people to just call him ben obi-wan kenobi
now that's a name i've not heard in a long
time most of these first couple of episodes
though are meant to show you how he is able
to find hope again but when you see him first
in episode one here the way that ewan mcgregor
talks about him he said he's meant to be at his
lowest point like things cannot get worse for him
the series is meant to show how he was able
to find hope again thus the title of episode 4
a new hope that's why right after this scene they
also show you what was happening with young leia
on alderaan because she is the other new hope for
the galaxy there's a lot of double meanings with
the titles of star wars movies but a new hope yes
luke skywalker is the main character of that film
but the whole idea is that leia is meant to be the
other hope like yoda said there is another leia is
the other new hope for everyone in the galaxy if
something were to happen to luke skywalker she's
meant to have just as much potential in the force
even though she doesn't wind up training quite as
much as luke does like she does some training as
they explain later in the timeline but she leaves
her training even though they call her master
later in the timeline and throughout the episode
she does seem super precocious like they want
to make her seem as much like padme as possible
and everybody is sassy and as resourceful as you
remember leia being during the original trilogy
will somebody get this big walking carpet out of
my way no reward is worth this but even though
a lot of the things that she does like kind of
reading people so to speak make it seem like she's
unconsciously using the force i think a lot of
that is just meant to be her own natural ability
and just reading people like a normal person
would like a normal profiler would just be able
to look at people and read their body language
and learn everything about them just based on
the way that they act the woman that walks in
here is called brija organa she's her adoptive
mother bail organa's wife we've never seen a ton
of footage of her before but obviously because
this is a series we have a bunch of episodes they
have way more time to spend with the characters
all these scenes are just meant to show you what
life was like for her growing up on alderaan
what her relationships were with bail organa her
adoptive father with her mother how she actually
did love them how she cared about the people of
alderaan so that later in the timeline when you're
forced to watch her see as the planet blows up
you have way more context for her reaction now
her little droid is called lola supposedly they're
going to be selling that as a toy pretty soon
pretty much anything in star wars that's capable
of being sold as a toy will be sold as a toy when
she starts spotting all the transports and the
ships leaving the planet they just want to show
you how intelligent she is at this young age and
how she was able to eventually become the youngest
senator in the history of the galaxy she mentions
a tri-wing and aqualin ranger casino ship medical
freighter a lot of these ships would be ships that
wound up building the rebellion's fleet also the
guards that come with her mother to try and find
her are wearing helmets that look exactly like
helmets you see running around the rebellion's
bases it's just meant to show you how important
bail organa and leia eventually would become in
the formation of the rebellion itself a lot of the
forces from alderaan wound up making up the body
of the rebellion she also mentions mercon pirates
that's a group that was mostly active during the
clone wars that the separatists supported there
are several references during the series to the
actual clone wars because we literally just got
done experiencing those in the timeline of the
movies even though this is meant to be 10 years
later it relies heavily upon what happened during
revenge of the sith in the clone wars her mother
mentions a glorag that's a new creature that's
not from the canon before so i'm assuming it's a
wild tree animal that just lives on the planet you
notice that leia's clothing is very 70s inspired
similar to the designs in the color patterns you
see her wearing when she gets all of her clothing
changes during the original trilogy but also she's
got some epic bun themed hair just like she has
the cinnamon bun looking hair during a new hope
her mother has it too so i think the idea is that
it's just a common fashion amongst the people of
alderaan her mother makes all kinds of jokes about
her becoming a senator quickly like i said leia
was the youngest senator in the history of the
galaxy they use all these scenes at their party
here at the main palace to kind of show you what
her personality was like and why she thought the
way that she did during the original trilogy why
she fought so hard for common people and to kind
of show you what was going on with the other side
of things because there's this whole idea that the
emperor wound up overthrowing the republic to name
himself emperor create the empire the whole rise
of the empire itself but he wasn't able to do that
all by himself even though he was a sith lord he
required the help of many many powerful people
around the galaxy many powerful families that
supported him that's why they show you the sisters
family who kind of make it seem like they really
only care about making money they're not really
worried about what happens to the common people
and her son or their son is just like them with
bail organa and leia kind of taking them both to
task separately like there's a lot of other issues
that we need to be worried about in the senate
and leia basically telling the other little kid
that he needs to pay attention to what's really
going on they also reveal c3po and remember it is
the actual c3po and r2d2 is around here somewhere
too because they became bail organa's property at
the end of revenge of the sith and he only
had c-3po's memory wiped meaning that r2d2
as per canon remembers everything from the
prequels have the protocol droid's mind wiped what
is also meant to establish how the two of them
wound up on leia's ship during rogue one and
during a new hope when she's arguing with her
cousin she talks about jack beast those are
force sensitive animals that live in the outer
rim icy environments then they jump back to
obi-wan kenobi and they have that big scene with
his confrontation with owen lars and remember
it's joel edgerton he also played owen lars during
revenge of the sith so many years ago if you don't
remember all the same actors from this obi-wan
kenobi luke skywalker seen on owen lars farmstead
is meant to be the exact same actors except for
the baby obviously a lot of their argument about
what luke should and should not be doing about
staying hidden just keeping a normal life is meant
to reference the conversation that obi-wan kenobi
has with him later in the timeline alec guinness
version about why his uncle hated the idea of
obi-wan kenobi the jedi for sensitives in general
mostly because he felt like it led to too much
trouble yes they do have that funny scene of him
sassing obi-wan kenobi throwing anakin skywalker
in his face when the time comes he must be trained
like you trained his father but they also want to
use this scene to redeem owen lars character and
just explain why it was he hated these force
sensitives so much because the inquisitors
basically run roughshod almost winding up killing
him like reva almost kills him if not for the
other inquisitor stopping her to his credit though
he does not sell obi-wan kenobi out but as he says
he did it for luke skywalker's benefit not for
obi-wan kenobi because eventually they would have
tortured him and he felt like obi-wan kenobi would
have given up the information about luke and leia
eventually the funny thing with reva overstepping
over and over here like she's just going way over
the line at every turn makes it seem like darth
vader might wind up being the one to eventually
kill her it kind of reminded me of that funny
scene from rogue one where director credit where
orson krennic's character starts talking to darth
vader and darth vader tells him be careful not to
choke on your ambitions as he literally force
chokes the life out of him basically telling
krennic not to get too big for his britches and it
sounds like the same thing might wind up happening
to reva's character like be careful not to be too
ambitious because nobody is going to replace me
in the eyes of the emperor a lot of times darth
vader wanted to kill all the force sensitive's
knowledge of force sensitives so that the emperor
could not train another replacement for him and
just get rid of him also they kind of already
did this plot during jedi fallen order one of the
inquisitors who's a main character winds up kind
of turning good and sparing calcus and darth vader
then kills her for that so either way it seems
like reva is in some danger later bail organa
starts talking to her about his plans when he was
a child like i want to do all these great things
he talks about cthulhu which sounds like another
distant land the pergol that he talks about though
are those giant space whales that you see at the
end of star wars rebels that can enter hyperspace
naturally he also references her eventually
becoming a senator at a very young age just
kind of setting up her later in the timeline it
all winds up coming to pass they also use the
episode to show you how much he actually did care
about her as his adopted daughter they have one
of their first big cameo scenes from flea of red
hot chili peppers who plays the league kidnapper
one of the other kidnappers is also a falleen
who's the same race as prince zizer they reveal
that they're working for reva the inquisitor who's
trying to root out obi-wan kenobi because he is
the bigger prey the bigger fish that she was
talking about earlier trying to win more favor
from the emperor but the whole thing here is that
they don't know anything about her true identity
reva and all the inquisitors in the kidnappers
just think that they're stealing somebody who
is from a powerful family and they have a friend
obi-wan kenobi that will help them out and that's
where they're going to get them they don't know
anything about leia's true identity i also think
that's meant to be a bit of a joke about the canon
like how unlikely it was that all these characters
were able to keep their true identity secret up
to the events of the original trilogy but then
bail organa gives obi-wan kenobi his next big call
to action which he again refuses like he literally
has to show up in person to tell him get up off
your ass go save this girl you know how important
she is and the way that he explains it is that
they can't get somebody else like a bounty hunter
like even boba fett they can't hire because they
can't tell him who she really is because that'll
wind up revealing their secret they can't make
it public in the senate and create this big thing
because that'll also draw too much attention
to her true identity and when he says that leia
is just as important as luke skywalker is it's
meant to be another reference to them both being
a new hope like both of the two of them are twins
they have an equal chance of saving the galaxy
when they're locking her up in their little cell
inside the ship that's meant to be evocative of
the scene of her being put in her cell in the
death star and they do try to show her trying
to rescue herself which he does several times
throughout the series as i said they referenced
his talk earlier to the other rogue jedi about
burying his lightsaber in the sand when he
unveils his lightsaber health as well as anakin
skywalker's old lightsaber hilt and he finally
agrees to bail organa's demands that he go find
and save leia also probably didn't help seeing
the dead body that wrote jedi that he failed to
help earlier if it wasn't clear it seemed like
some townspeople got together and poisoned him
or somehow got the better of him and that's how
he died it was meant to be the inquisitors that
killed him because they'd already left the planet
like i said he's still kind of down in the dumps
so to speak the rest of the episodes are meant to
sort of give him the inspiration that there will
be a new hope there is new hope for the future
referencing the title of the episode 4 movie they
play a little of john williams classic force theme
song at the end of the episode when he reveals
his lightsaber hilts but then over the end credits
it's all meant to be brand new music that they
compose for the series if you spotted any other
easter eggs or references during the episode that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments what will happen though
is that my full episode 2 video will post next
later today that should be up in the next couple
of hours so make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
for my full obi-wan kenobi episode 2 video i'll
update the link as soon as i post that and click
here for all my obi-wan kenobi trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!